The task that we want the robot to do is to
position the end of this rod to the tip of
this rod, and that’s a relatively easy thing
for me to do. I’m using both my eyes to
guide my hand in order to achieve that particular
motion. However, if I’m only using one eye
there is a potential for some ambiguity. Using
just a single eye, it’s actually quite difficult
for me to determine the distance along the
axis away from my eye. In order to achieve
this positioning task in three dimensions,
I actually need to use two camera views and
the cameras need to be at different viewpoints.
Here is a simple graphical representation
of the problem that we just looked at. We
have the blue object which is fixed, and we
have the red object which is moving, and we
want to bring the tip of the red object to
the tip of the blue object. And this is clearly
a task that occurs in three-dimensional space.
Now, consider that we have a camera observing
the task and we see here the camera’s view.
We see the blue object and the red object.
So when the task is accomplished, we see what
it looks like in the camera’s eye view,
and we see that in this two-dimensional projection
of the task occurring that the tip of the
red object is brought to the tip of the blue
object. So the task is being achieved in the
image as well as being achieved in three-dimensional
space.
It’s not quite that simple.
Consider now that I perform the task incorrectly.
I bring the red object to this position. Now,
the task has not been achieved: the tip of
the red object has not met the tip of the
blue object in three-dimensional space. But
in the image plane, the task looks like it
has been achieved. We can say that in this
horizontal direction, we can observe the motion
of the red object. But in this direction away
from the camera, we are unable to observe
the motion of the object.
So we have an observable degree of freedom
and we have an un-observable degree of freedom.
Another way we can think about this problem
is that with the camera, we are making a measurement.
It’s a measurement u,v: the coordinate of
the red object in the image plane. So we’ve
got two measurements. We are measuring two
numbers, u and v. Then our task occurs in
three-dimensional space: our task has got
three degrees of freedom. So two measurements
is insufficient to achieve a task with three
degrees of freedom.
Now, let’s consider that we perform this
with two cameras having a look at the task
that’s being accomplished. These cameras
have got different viewpoints. So if we perform
a task, we can now see how it looks in each
camera view. This time, the task is being
achieved correctly. Now, we are making four
measurements about what’s going on. We are
measuring u and v in one camera. We are measuring
u and v with another camera. Now, we’ve
got four measurements, and that is sufficient
to achieve a task with three degrees of freedom.
So in order to achieve a task, the number
of measurements must be greater than or equal
to the number of degrees of freedom.
A long time ago, we actually built a real
robot system to do this. Now, the task was
to insert a tool, which is shown here, in
to a hole in the roof of an underground mining
tunnel. There is a camera on each side of
the robot’s tool tip and it’s observing
the hole in the roof; and you can see that
shown here as the green region. And what the
control system is doing is to bring the tip
of the tool to the center of the green region
simultaneously in both camera views. And if
it does that, then it means that implicitly
the tool has been put in to the hole in the
roof of the mining tunnel.
Let’s recap on the difference between vision-based
control and conventional robot control.
In conventional robot control, the observation
of the pose of the robot’s end effector
is indirect. We use sensors that measure the
angles of the joints, and we use a kinematic
model to compute where the end of the robot
is. So it is just inferred.
We also need to be told the position of the
object in Cartesian space and then the task
of the controller is to bring the inferred
position of the robot’s end effector to
the position of the object which we know in
advance.
Vision-based control by contrast is direct
observation of the tool, and of the object,
and of the error between those two things.
In vision-based control, we try and drive
that error to zero. We don’t actually know
the pose of the object. We don’t actually
know the pose of the robot’s tool. We simply
observe the error and drive that to zero.
This is a technique that’s commonly called
visual servoing.
There are many potential uses of visual servoing.
For instance, in a manufacturing operation,
we may need to pick up objects that are randomly
placed on a conveyor belt. Visual servoing
could guide the tip of a robot to pick up
these objects as they are moving past. It
could also be used to grab objects which are
swinging on an overhead transfer line for
example. It could be used for a mating task,
perhaps to put fueling nozzle in to a car,
into a spacecraft, or an aircraft.
Consider a problem like fruit picking. We
don’t know the x, y, and z location of every
apple in the orchard. Perhaps, we don’t
even know the location of the robot within
the orchard. But using this visual control
strategy, a robot can reach out and reduce
the error between its tool tip and an apple
to zero. In which case, then it has achieved
a grasp of that fruit and can remove it from
the tree.
We could consider the problem of landing an
aircraft on a runway. We observe the runway.
We can see some very obvious visual features
there: some nice white lines, some nice white
rectangles, and we could use those to control
the aircraft so that its height above the
runway becomes zero while being aligned with
that runway.
It could be used for keeping an underwater
robot at a fixed location despite an ocean
current trying to push it away from where
it wants to be. It could be used to guide
an underwater robot following an underwater
pipeline. It could be used for tasks like
juggling and so on. The applications of vision-based
control are almost limitless.